wow
what's that cc
with cc it's short for computer cleaner
like duster show me the cam
and you inhale that yes what does it do
for you
it gives me high it gives me like well
some people say that it gets you like
but it doesn't make me feel like that i
feel like
awesome i'm just awesome but i can do
anything you know
and nobody can tell me anything because
i don't care
are there other drugs you use or is this
a replacement for something
um i'm not a replacement i use other i
mean i smoke weed
and i smoke cigarettes and um
and computer cleaner yeah dust off
duster dust off the other one's desktop
this is duster
this is our endorsement it's like seven
bucks it's like
okay you could say it's a replacement
for um
from the nas tanks
the stuff you put in the balloons you go
that's how this
okay then all things feel a little bit
different i like how this makes you feel
personally
like before that but that's
another thing it tastes better and it's
healthier for you if you want to talk
about healthy even though it's
bad you'll do this all day long um no
i'll do it sometimes throughout the day
or whenever like i just feel like doing
it
but it's not like i could stop doing it
but it is a dick you know
it does feel good and it makes people
addicted to it you know i think people
do crazy [ __ ] on this
like what like pass out on the side of
the street
or just act like a crazy fool like
totally other person you know
and then when they're done they won't
remember
people have seizures on this do all
kinds of crazy [ __ ]
but i don't ever overuse it like that
when you overuse it well too much of
anything is bad for you know
to be honest with you so when you reuse
it of course you're gonna get a bad
result
right so you take it with you when
you're working fig
yeah well i mean well it's probably more
concealed like in my purse but it's not
showing to the whole world
but how long you've been working fake um
that or like how long have i been on the
street either one
i've been on the stream since i was like
young you know before i turned 18.
but i've been working fake since i was
like 20
were you working before uh-huh where
were you working before fake
i was in like i wasn't working i wasn't
like trying i had a boyfriend that was
really whack
like he just i thought he loved me but
that was not the abusive you know
whatever
and i was like for like a year and a
half and um
and then when i left him is when i went
back on the street that's when i started
working
before that i was just like in the
streets you know running around i had a
boyfriend
and i wasn't with him i was my my friend
was like my brother kind of just like
bowing it you know i just got tired of
bumping it you've had tennis before
uh-huh have you had temps before how
well pimp
pam um i wouldn't call it that
a business associate a boyfriend slash
business manager
yeah whatever you wanna if you wanna
call you know my um
my bodyguard if we will
that i pay to protect me right yeah you
give him the money
no not all of it cause at the end of the
day is
how i wanna i'm not gonna make nobody
force me to or nobody can force me do
anything and i don't
already consent well that's a lie
because i mean
i've been in some situations you know
but for the most part i try not to put
myself in a situation where it's not how
i want to be
how old are you 22 22.
and you grew up where i'm from orange
county
you're from orange county well i was
born in orange county but
i use this i used to live like in the
high desert
tell me about your family tell me about
your childhood my childhood
um my mom was an escort
so and then um i don't know like i've
lived in almost like a lot of my life
like bad moments you know
and i have siblings but like i raised
them pretty much
my mom wouldn't really like have a part
in that kind of a thing dad
huh where's your dad my dad was there
but he was like
still young you know he was working all
the time and then like
if he wasn't working he was sleeping
type thing you know
and so for the most part like i just
can't take care of my siblings i was a
good kid for a while for
most of my childhood but then i started
[ __ ] about high school
whatever lucky's out of my house what to
do
ended up on the street met my
ex-boyfriend left him and then
he left talking about what age 16.
that's when they kicked me out my house
kicked you out yeah
before um because
i had they well they were under the
assumption that i had tried drugs but i
didn't
my sister did and she lied and said that
i didn't they believed
it and my stepmom was the ex tweaker for
like
22 years or something like that so she
was like tripping on it you know and she
convinced my dad to kick me out
so drug you started for you what age
when did you
start for me yeah like any drugs
including me
are just like the stronger the stronger
ones probably like
18 because i didn't start doing drugs
until i was already in the street for a
while
all my friends were doing it but i
didn't do it and then i did it because i
got tired of falling asleep and i wake
up and like my [ __ ] would be gone
except triggers you know i mean like
crazy [ __ ]
i look crazy doing it it's interesting
i look crazy huh you look a little crazy
but you would never know if you didn't
see me hit it
you even know that i maybe i'm high or
something like that but not that i do
this no
no it's not like it's not like i do it
i'm crazy out of control you're drunk or
something no
it looks like i'm drunk no not it's not
like you're drunk or something yeah i'm
not right i'm acting pretty normal
right see now if you saw somebody else
do this and you saw how they react
you just trip out because they've
totally flopped we call it flopping
when you just trip out and you don't
know what to do like they have seizures
like it looks like they're having a
seizure but
they have like specimens to start
shaking and go crazy people
drool people falling in their faces and
don't even remember
on this and you think you're addicted to
duster
um i think i'm addicted to a lot of
things
i'm going to do the duster i'm going to
do cigarettes i'm going to weed i'm
addicted to i'm just going to do sex i'm
addicted to
a lot of people have addictions of all
sorts i mean everybody whether it's
eating should be addicted to reading
your bible you're still interested in
shopping laziness
comfort kinds of things and we don't we
don't even know it sometimes
and the fact that we don't know it
because we're not consciously aware of
what we're doing
at least that's how i feel
to be consciously aware of what you're
doing you're a step ahead of the game a
little bit at least you know
most people just go on blindly doing
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing not
paying no attention to mine
how do you feel about doing sex work how
do you feel about
your careers as a prostitute
i think that at the end of the day like
[ __ ] are here
giving away their [ __ ] for free right
so why not charge somebody who wants my
time
time is money right yeah
whether it's [ __ ] whether there's
guys that just want to kick it they
don't even want to [ __ ] they just want
to hang out and then what like
for a good price why not you make an
argument for that huh
you can make an argument for that i see
your [ __ ] changes a lot of [ __ ] in the
world
right or wrong it turns down a lot of
dynasties it brings them up as well you
know
as long as you know what to do with it
and as long as even though you
even though i do whatever i do like i
don't let nobody disrespect me
you know what i mean the people i [ __ ]
with they respect me at least i would
say they do and when they don't i stop
[ __ ] with them
you know you have to have a basic
like mutual respect when you meet
somebody i think and then that level of
respect will either rise
or lower depending on their actions you
know
you've been in love before
that's a true question yeah what's your
question or what
no i'm just asking i've been comfortable
have you been alive
in love um something that i might
think is in love you're only 21 so it's
not like you're [ __ ] yeah i don't think
it's love maybe what i have
felt i mean like when my ex i thought he
loved me but i was wrong
i think that i have somebody that i love
right now
i mean i don't think so no not truly in
though
i mean maybe though i have i feel like i
have them it's a complicated question
yes it is love is a hard thing and the
answer doesn't have to be yes or no
and i'm saying i still think that i
think that
people can have many loves in their life
like you could love many people you know
in different ways
your soul mate is a different story i
think personally
that's somebody that you just have an un
conditional bond of
you don't even know for you know i mean
that's the difference right and i
haven't met my soul mate yet but
do i think i've been in love and do i
have love for people yeah
do i care a little bit too much
sometimes probably
but it is what it is i don't change my
character for nobody
and well i'll change it for myself when
i want to you know but not for nobody
else
or not because i have to or i want to be
a certain way like that's who i am
i like having sex sometimes well you
guys
most of the time i don't just [ __ ]
people that i just don't have no
attraction to it all whatsoever
well i have a couple times they're not
like you know what i mean
you're you know strangers are coming up
to you on the street and picking you up
and you're driving
if they're cute or not you turn them
down if they're not
i mean if they're weird and i guess i'm
pretty good at reading people
yeah you have to be right so if they're
weird and
just i'm good but some guys just keep me
like oh you want to kick in smoke and
sometimes that's all that it is
and then i mean a friend that's how you
make friends right a lot of guys just
want a girl to get high with right
yeah like just to hang out they get
lonely whatever
a lot of them have their whole lives
that separate lives that they don't want
nobody knowing about
that they just want to get out and have
a good time a lot of your clients
married yeah like don't be married you
have girlfriends
like they stay friends with me and i'll
i'll meet their girlfriends
and i'll be cool with them but i don't
ever get out of my boundaries or step on
nobody's toes or
disrespect anybody and if i know their
girlfriends or something i won't go on
that level you know i mean
but most of the time it's people they
have whole lives that i don't even know
about
that those people never know about me i
never know about them and it stays like
that
does work ever get to you emotionally
sometimes
in what ways all kinds of ways like i
get self-conscious
i think i'm not doing that good for
myself or whatever but at the same time
like
[ __ ] doing music videos shaking their
ass for a quick dollar like
what is it to anybody else what i'm
doing i don't tell nobody else how to
live their life
do you feel any shame over doing this
work um
i would think so sometimes but at the
same time like i don't let it bring me
down
yeah why should i feel shame i think the
day guys [ __ ] whoever they want whatever
they want for free and they don't give a
[ __ ]
and at the end of the day if a guy
doesn't care about my well-being hell
yeah i'm going to charge them it's an
interesting career because
it's like it's like interest like when
you when you let somebody borrow some
money it's because you know you're going
to get something back right
like a little bit more than what you let
them borrow so if i let somebody borrow
my time i better get something back free
because
i'm paying they better be paying in some
type of way so make sure that i know
that i'm safe
collateral whatever you want to call it
if i'm going to kick it with somebody
yeah i'm going to charge you because i
need to make sure that my well-being is
good before yours is right
it's an interesting career and that you
know guys are giving you compliments all
day long and they're paying you for your
you know but see you got to be careful
to decipher the ones that are full of
[ __ ] and the ones that are actually
about it yeah but then it also probably
undermines your self-worth depending on
the situation
and depending on the guys too like some
guys really keep it discreet and they're
not like that other guys
like for instance if they be in the
scene or ibia like they have a big mouth
those are kids you know i mean you
really have to try harder to see through
those
and try not to get those because they're
not good for you i mean they're just
they just bring you down at the end of
the day or make you look a certain type
of way but if people [ __ ] with you
i think they [ __ ] with you regardless of
what other people say
as long as you can look past that and
like i don't want to talk to anybody i
can't trust
i know that if somebody came up to me on
the street and told me hey my home
girl's talking [ __ ] on me
i'm gonna be like i know you're [ __ ]
lying because my humble girl would never
do that
and i don't feel the same way and when
you come to that mutual agreement that
that's not gonna happen
because you can't you can't be with
somebody and not have that trust
especially against the world because the
world will tear you down
you know
[Music]
do i sound crazy or am i making sense
no you're making sense perfect sense
perfect sense pretty good
pretty smart i'm really smart actually
i got straight a's in school you did
straight is i was in marching band i got
a medal for being the best clarinet
player in my whole school's district
i was in choir i was in um
i was in color guard right through the
flags and the rifles and [ __ ] yeah are
you a good girl it went bad
oh are you a good girl that went on i'm
not gonna say i went bad but like
[ __ ] happened and i kind of like went
down that way because i wasn't in the
right place
because i don't know where to live and
she likes oh i got put in a certain
situation i'm not going to blame nobody
else
obviously it's my fault and i'm not
doing this and change it right now and
you got to survive
yeah but you know i'm going to change
the world one day
just believe i know that and people that
know me know that you know
just because it's not right now but
patience is a virtue yeah
with time from good things come with
time you know you get these desensitized
to the dangers of doing this work
what do you mean yeah guys robbing you
beating you up raping i've been raped
twice that's what i'm talking about and
um
i've been beat up i've been defeated if
most women went to work and got raped
they probably wouldn't go back to that
job again
i mean yeah but you know what it is is
another addiction people are addicted to
the quick money
or the abuse i'm not addicted to the
abuse i wouldn't say
or the disrespect i'm not but you know
like
both times that i've been raped it
wasn't doing work
i wasn't working without any work so
i can't say that you know i probably got
more respect from certain guys
doing that job than than not doing it
and them taking me
taking advantage of me or them just
thinking that i'm just some [ __ ] or
whatever you know
at least when i charge them some of them
have a certain type of respect for me
do you think there's any chance of you
ever falling in love with one of your
tricks
that was one of my tricks falling in
love one day of course yeah
you know i've never been married i want
to get married i want to have kids i
don't have kids
but i will one day i'm gonna be a good
parent you know i'm gonna be
when that happens my whole life will
change but that has to be somebody like
very like
that has to be a totally uh it's a whole
other you know i mean
it's a whole conversation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you think doing this kind of work
has changed you
changed me yeah
[Music]
i could say for the better but i could
also save for not so much the better
like it's changed me for the better in a
way where like
i think i'm a little bit more streetwise
obviously i have some respect
i have i've grown some i grow some balls
like i've got some ladybugs and i and i
think that i've gotten like my chest got
a little bigger you know
your intuition must be uh heightened uh
your intuition must be
yeah like i'm gonna say that being in
the streets has also opened my eyes to a
lot of [ __ ] that
i've seen so many people so naive and
get taken advantage of
and it's because i had i didn't have
people to put me up on game but i chose
my teachers and you still choose your
teachers
every day right so i chose this if i
chose to learn from or
certain things that i try i try to take
something from everything in life
because i feel like
you you have to be a sponge for
knowledge or for other [ __ ] you know you
need to be a sponge for
for good [ __ ] right
absolutely if you put good things out in
the universe you'll get good things back
karma you know karma's a [ __ ] but when
you realize what a beautiful [ __ ] she
is
do you think you're addicted to this
this kind of work
i think that i'm addicted to quick money
fast money
because you know like it's a date thing
it is addicting
they say money could be more addicting
than drugs anything sex i mean
it's really just a person's perception
how you choose to look at a situation
how you let it view you that's what
really matters you know
nobody else has to deal with you but you
right so
you have to explain yourself to nobody
now i explain myself to people because i
feel like i want to not because i have
to because i want to so that they get a
little piece of me every time they meet
me you know
but there are some people that don't
even feel they need to even talk to and
i just want to talk to them
i'm on my business i don't make no
scenes i don't cause no problems
i'm not drama i'm a team player if
anything like i'm not a hater you know
i try to bring females up rather than
shut them down because we get turned on
by enough people
right yeah tell me what you've learned
about men
doing this kind of work well men are
dogs that's inevitable
by the same time like say for instance
i'm in a relationship right
i like the whole loyalty team yeah of
course but at the end of the day men are
going to be men
so whatever he does when he's out as
long as he's
[ __ ] remembering he's talking to
whatever as long as they know
who i am i have a certain type of
respect for me as a female as whatever
as his female
he comes home to me at night and that's
what he sleeps with and they know their
place or whatever then i'm cool you know
just out of sight out of mind don't let
me see that [ __ ] don't let it be put on
friendship with me don't make me look
stupid
it will be cool keep it real you know
keep it 400 if you can't tell me the
truth i don't want to be with you
you can tell me [ __ ] some girl at least
i know cause you [ __ ] me i'm not going
to go and
you know what i'm saying but see what
the thing is guys can't live with
themselves a lot of the time
so they don't want to tell you what they
did because they can't even tell
themselves and be okay with it because
they know what's wrong
especially being the fact that you know
i do be loyal so guys
you know most person jump away because
at the end of the day i know where my
loyalty stands
you know
i look 22 yeah i'd buy 22.
it could be 18 too though too really it
could be 18.
that was good right but i look younger i
i'm not saying it's good or bad i'm just
saying you look
you could be younger than 22. no i'm 22.
i wish i was 18. you're tired
this town makes 200 drowsy but not bad
drowsy like i'm just yawning because
i don't know that's funny
it feels good it's like taking a deep
breath like i'll take a deep breath
sometimes people are like what's wrong
nothing's wrong i'm just you know taking
your breath it's good for you
do you ask to do risky stuff with guys
like do you get asked to do stuff like
without a condom or that's like the
least risky stuff
that's like the less risky stuff that
happens that's the least of the risk you
should try it out don't tell me the risk
of your stuff that you do
kinds of [ __ ] like people are weird i've
never [ __ ] in the ass but people ask
the [ __ ] ass
i'm like that's not gonna happen you
know like nope
never have never will people have asked
me to
dress up just so they can look at my
feet people have done weird [ __ ] people
have asked to pee on me
hell no they want me to pee on them
people are just weird yeah guys are
weird
do you think it's guys or women i'm not
gonna say no i think that some women are
weird too but
me personally like yeah i'm a freak yeah
this makes me a little biggie i like
watching porn i like doing that but
i don't do no weird [ __ ] like the whole
ain't nothing weird
okay for sure like the whole peeing on
thing
that's disgusting that's just you don't
do that you know people say if i'm a
squirter but i've never squared it
before but
i'm not saying it's not possible but me
percent never done it before
are you saving money i try to
but i survive to have to survive and
people take up take my [ __ ] sometimes
i don't have no stable to live because
it's like [ __ ] are you staying in my
motel the motel
yeah that's what most of the girls do
but you know i've been trying to get a
stable spot i'm not trying to be in the
scene with that
are there other drugs you're currently
using other than duster
i smoke dope sometimes
and i smoke cigarettes and weed and
that's it i don't even drink
what's your biggest regret what's your
biggest regret
i don't really have a regret because at
the end of the day i wanted to do that
at some point right
it's not like i didn't want to do it so
i can't say i regret it or that i
i can't talk [ __ ] about it because at
one point i wanted to do that thing
maybe my biggest work is not finishing
school but i'm going to finish school
it's unfinished but i'm going to finish
you'll see you watch it i'm going to
change the world one day
you'll see that they're like
i knew that girl
i swear what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
you can't trust anybody and i hear that
one a lot
it's a cold world it's a cold world but
on the polar bear
at the end of the day i don't like i
mean
everybody tells me like i'm a genuinely
happy person for the [ __ ] that i've been
through
and the [ __ ] that i'm going through and
the stuff that i live with every day
i'm a happy ass person you don't ever
see me disappointed you never see me
finding nobody you don't ever see me
upset
if i'm gonna say it's because
something's getting to me you know and
then they people like what's wrong with
you
because they know me they know i'm cool
i'll give the shirt off my back to
somebody
i have before i've given this lady the
shoes off my feet
because she needed more than i did so
that's nothing to me you know
i am who i am if you [ __ ] get down
you're like oh you're white was it i
don't care my black friends be like girl
black isn't white is the new black i'm
like shut up
should we tell you that you know she's
like girl you thick for a white girl
someone was like were you one of them
corn fed white girls i'm like what
you know i'd be [ __ ] with everything
i'm quoting judge nobody
i ain't god i'm nobody to judge nobody i
don't want to be judged
you know so don't judge me i wanted you
as long as you expect me to sleep at
night i'll respect you to sleep at night
we can agree to disagree
and we'll be kosher i'm switzerland
neutral right
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story mm-hmm
i wish you the best of luck out there be
careful thank you
don't oh d on that duster i won't
it's i might od on sex from it maybe
because that's what i'm doing i'm behind
but it doesn't
i won't do that i want od if you if you
see me only you better stop me
and be like i know you you're supposed
to change the world and you're over here
od
nothing i would never
cool